hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
youtubers react to try not to get mad
challenge this is a top reward to your
video requests from a beautiful man
whose nipple I would lick named Eric
horseman it was his birthday very
recently so happy birthday to Eric you
know we love this [ __ ] at it yet I
watched haunting of Hill House primarily
because of you you were the guy who got
the real rejects tattoo the day you find
out when you're gonna be dying soon let
us know we will fly to Atlanta and we
will meet you you have our word you have
my word not his he's as reliable but you
have my word I'll show up at the very
end just as you're about to die yeah and
then he'll linger way too long in the
hospital room talk to all of the
different doctors and stuff and you know
the John reputation and then I'll get
caught a bunch of times on the way out
trying to help people on I was mad when
I tweeted that and I just as mad as I am
now
so we are here at VidCon one of the
happiest places on earth for a youtuber
yes we challenge I hate big ok I have a
hard time getting depends some like what
is being shown it's gonna send me off we
freaked out I already lost my voice was
screaming at a fast-food worker is this
good to play when I break I'm excited
are you just gonna show me a picture of
[Music]
[Music]
it's just processing at this point so
it's not really even uploading any more
but I don't know so I never know if I
can like just save changes and exit out
or if that will like ruin it what are
you doing now you can't the last 5% is
that the last 10 seconds of the video do
you have this problem with outros what
is the problem
literally youtubers react to try to get
that challenge it's this video how you
doing this in the future this is all of
our neighbors this is around the time we
might be trying to psychically gives you
time to fill out this description yeah I
didn't like this no I don't think I know
what it's it's everyday life at work
right now
[Music]
at this point you just turn you go into
sleep mode and you're like you know what
I'm gonna do is anything but watch this
happen
I mean I want to get mad at this oh my
god what happen I want to be I want to
be in the video
now those usually go to review section
now YouTube comments drive me crazy
[Music]
anymore I've just filtered every single
one of these comments like if you love
your money boner die I seen that a few
times as a real I always liked that
comment whatever you want you can
advertise your website your gift card
giveaway has such a big smile I'm so bad
and some people just always look like
they're smiling but each of comments as
a rule I don't know about that does this
happen
sure I do go back for people trying to
have a conversation with their viewers
it seems like it's the year of our our
2019 with the smartest computer programs
in the world Google should be able to
know about the fake stuff I mean they
know where I am all the time they know
what I'm interested in they know like
when I most recently ate Doritos how
come they can't get rid of sub4sub
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
and not even 1% of my video says this
beautiful yellow golden button right no
Mattie icon doesn't just mean that
you're bad it doesn't mean that your
videos just not going to get sharing the
algorithm but it means whether if you
ever pay or in it next month could you
imagine if you went to work at a normal
job and then just instead of getting
your paycheck you just got a yellow
money sign letting you know this week
you're not getting paid because you
sweared once at work this guy is failing
it's somebody else failed them all a
year ago this made us very very angry
but now I've got we figured out ok we
can't use the term weapons our
intertitles anymore we used to be like
ninja weapons and stuff okay now they're
another ninja gadgets you slowly figure
out you know what you can't do what you
can't do ever my life would be so
miserable and I would have given up a
very long time ago so I've seen things
like this and I'm just like oh ok yeah
this thing that we deal with and it's
like I guess I've trained myself not to
get anything I got 6 or just you counted
yes I just need you to check anything
off so yeah that's that's one of the
worst parts about the face you see
before you die
thank you creator
on YouTube are familiar with this icon
so if I wanna get you mad here's suppose
from YouTube creators issues they've had
with the website Craig Thompson saying
like he's he's trying to like you know
changed how his videos are to not swear
and then him not swearing his light
triggered YouTube to think he's swearing
more and he doesn't know what to do
anymore that's so upsetting I know that
so much of the queer community on
YouTube also suffers because of this
based off of videos that are just trying
to help educate and making people feel
yeah welcome I can't pretend to not be
upset about it just because like I feel
like that would mean me like pretending
to like adopt that attitude that I hate
like the truth the peace it's like no
there's something that can be done yeah
you guys music videos of all time yay
you'd be partnered with UMG meanwhile
mr. Reese responds and says they
literally could just use the hundreds of
thousands of dollars they profited of
just my videos to do this which is
referring to all the copyright claims
that he got for humming one of their
songs or maybe in the background a
trucker drove by and he was listening to
one of their songs last year I got like
17 emails from YouTube saying like this
video has been claimed this videos been
claimed this videos been claimed to
trial three days makes sense though most
of the time every video so mr. base has
shown all these copyright claims I feel
you there we have what you see a lot of
those Abused to be a lot of parodies
you're literally wrongfully that is
that's that's really
yes absolutely and I do get mad there's
a difference between things that are
frustrating and things that are unfair
and that that's like oh I'll get mad
that's becoming a real serious
especially to about people yeah I think
we're time now you can't make it on
YouTube unless you're a corporation a
p-series number one first of all that
pisses me off corporations they're gonna
think it's popular they monetize
enshrining manage the world
what's incredibly discouraging about a
pastor standing the internet way they
cookies I've been angry about it for so
long that's a great point though I do
miss the old days of you too I remember
it was like you know ray william johnson
raywilliamjohnson man whatever that guy
don't go burning
not surprising to me large corporations
have taken advantage of it and they're
using it to its max I have a whole team
putting on two tethers yeah so they
should be at the time yeah
thank you we get people automatically I
subscribed every day on the front page
you might be able to see 40 thumbnails
when there's 400 hours for the video
uploaded every minute
I understand that but they click that
subscribe button they will see that
subscription and then of course don't
forget the notification though because
the four million people that signed up
to my channel before the notification
belt ever existed they don't have
notifications turned off my channel how
could they it didn't exist if he didn't
grandfather them in so that's what we
needed was a second subscription button
thanks YouTube YouTube used to have a
subscription box front and center and
actually used to be when you went to
youtube.com it would show your
subscriptions immediately on the front
page now you have to be extra clips to
get to your subscription feed almost
nobody clicks there used to be you can
subscribe and that was enough and you
have now you also click the Bell and
then for awhile that seemed to be enough
and now it's just like they just kind of
do whatever they want doesn't matter you
can you can beg and plead to see a video
but if they don't want to show up to you
they're not going to show up to you
it is weird that when you click on the
notification Bell and like ass
do you want those applications all the
time or just sometimes and sometimes
people don't even realize them so they
click on sometimes because they're just
like okay I don't know what this means
and then they're like notifications for
your video you want to be able to and
ultimately YouTube one last video for
you guys save the best for last
any idea what this could be okay let's
say alright I think it's Rick Astley
that's not it's the girl who
see that the thing is it just makes me
happy that attention and release
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how can you get mad about getting ripped
rolls I love that it's a classic guys
great risk no they usually in your
aggression what is one thing you see
that makes precious I mean he does have
some kind of Eastern you positive you do
bring it back to do these interviews
collaborations and hang out with other
Creators the best friends meeting the
pants and hanging out the pants
entertaining you and keeping you guys
happy make sure you check out all of the
creators featured in this episode the
links are down below if this episode
make you mad let me know in the comments
bye y'all anncr
a shot at VidCon yeah look out I made a
YouTube bash video advic just going
right from the eye of the hurricane mad
respect respect the gutsy move right
there from the finebros but hey i mean
they're they're gutsy folks you know we
primarily do reactions here so we'll go
over all the topics they talked about
here well at least most of them personal
here's what I want to say to everything
that they talk about here I generally
I'm kind of sick of talking about this
[ __ ] is a weird reminder of like having
them all in one video if you know me in
real life you know that I generally
avoid YouTube talk we were at comic-con
ders someone who brought up to me he's
like so what's your schedule like what's
your upload like someone should start
asking all these questions I had to
literally just go I don't want to die
that's the first day I met this guy I
was like I don't want to talk about the
first reaction was oh you're not gonna
enjoy this conversation yeah because
everything there they're talking about
especially with like yellow dollar bill
signs or whatever when we first were
getting really hit with that and we're
still we still have the repercussions of
yellow dollar bill signs all the time
every reaction channel complaints about
new monetization or a nothing new yeah
there was a time where I was just stuck
in like infer like a solid year and a
half of just like negativity and I had
to just move past it there are some
stuff here or one guy was talking about
the nature of the beast and whatever
there are some sites who were I am just
like yeah that it's just the way
business is and I think a lot of times
when people starve YouTube channels they
forget to factor in that this is a
business and try [ __ ] forget that any
business any industry is subject to
change beyond your control anything you
participate in YouTube was this
beautiful and still is in a lot of ways
this really cool platform that has
allowed people to put up their stuff for
free on this like huge was a website and
then you could earn a profit off of it
that's crazy you know I think about that
that it's like we're so used to the
concept of them YouTube offering that
but that's still fairly new
it's always been a bit of a bummer
people always talk about YouTube steals
my money u2 steals this even from the
very beginning before all this stuff
happened with algorithm changes in
yellow dollar bill signs the rules of
fair use are beyond confusing now you
know people are like 10 seconds 20
seconds I've got in this video blocked
worldwide for 5 seconds what is the fair
use rule here I get it the common rule
of thumb is YouTube takes what is it
like 45% of your Adsense revenue and
then you get a big ok 55% I think that's
what it is but then again it's like
you're putting up your content for free
you're not yeah but I'm your [ __ ]
they're giving me the UI and all of the
server space right see what I'm doing
right now imagine this this is the dick
of you tip end over John is it is weird
to go back and see all of these in a
condensed space because yes so much of
it now does feel like ok these are just
the pitfalls that come with any platform
or something like that cuz you are just
at the mercy of YouTube and I think this
what this is taught everybody is that
YouTube itself still is kind of the same
thing it's always been anybody can get
an account and upload and find people
who want to see that when it comes to
all of this stuff I think this has
really taught us the importance of
diversity and like with the advent of
patreon really taking off it's showing
people that you can't perhaps only rely
on YouTube because you're always going
to be subject to whatever they want to
do with their platform and however they
want to accommodate their advertisers
and so you're just not gonna ever have
all the control that you want you know
no and when it comes to change it's
usually in the hands of the people like
the viewers it's like a big saving grace
for a lot of this has been the viewers
patron ah being a prime example of it I
feel like viewers in general have been
way less critical of seeing sponsorship
deals or brand deals at the top of
videos or in the middle of videos there
was a time before any of this mattered
you know like a second you had a brand
deal freaking sellouts too did Adele
when it was always part of the game
that's always part of the growth and
doing this kind of work now more people
than ever are doing more brand deals
because they have to beyond that though
I noticed that viewers
less likely to there's always those
people who do exist rexella I just don't
understand but for the most part I've
noticed less dislike something because
there's a brand deal there's more
support for getting brand deals now most
people have patreon pages now so viewers
have really helped keep things alive so
and I think that weirdly enough vlogging
like the popularity of vlogging really
helps because I'm sure that through that
window a lot of people have gotten to
see what the actual life is like not
that every youtube show has the same
lifestyle but a lot of that home-based
business stuff that people might not
realize is involved and everything's
like the perspectives I think from the
fan side are different now too because
the the layers the veils are thinner
since like I started doing the reactions
here reactions in general were just like
freaking hate it off it's crazy and then
we were at Comic Con I had a lot of
really in-depth conversations with
struggle nation you might know ECOMOG
media group and also fail well they were
telling me how reactions are just a
category on YouTube now and to see where
reaction channels have grown beyond just
a few people doing it and how they were
once consider the cancer of YouTube and
now like so many people do it so many
channels have implemented it into their
channels as well it's because of viewers
at becoming a more acceptable of changes
and acceptable of something new
happening so now more than ever when
people say stuff like it's because of
you guys the fans I've always thought
that was kind of pretentious and I've
always found it to be rather false
logically speaking the gratitude is
well-earned to us towards the viewers
like to you guys when people say that
like see you guys because it's because
of you guys that people can still have
channels now that people can still
thrive that things can adapt and grow
and change happens amongst the medium
whether it is people atop the
corporations who are usually can
maneuver everything around and generally
kind of screwed over content creators it
was around the time we start patreon I'm
like I feel like some people who say it
still sound fake but for me personally
when I thank the viewers I really I
don't say it every day but I do feel it
every day and when I say it I really
mean it so thank you guys the
relationship is just different now and I
think that's a really beautiful thing
about the resurgence or the the upswing
of patreon is just that kind of direct
you know transaction between artists and
the
people who want their creation you know
yeah whatever that may be I think that's
a really simple way to do things and it
does kind of show okay what works what
does and it helps you kind of grow your
operation too in a different way because
you can focus in it it's funny I found
out there's this reactions even exist on
TV there's a show in the UK called
goggle box that I had no idea existed
that's been going for years and years
there's people reacting to TV shows
watching TV making comments they just
cut to a bunch of different households
and has been going on for ages and so
like learning that to like helped bring
the perspective like okay just cuz this
is on the internet doesn't mean that
it's not valid and other people have
been doing this even on TV like yeah
definitely you know and and this has
also changed how I use YouTube too
because now more than ever I let ads
play or I'll hit the like button or all
just interact in ways I never used to in
ways knowing all of this for as much as
there is to [ __ ] about can also hope
the community because it makes yeah well
honestly think that there's there's
always room for a reasonable amount of
complaining and anything in life there
is a point though that I see with a lot
of people involved in this field
especially I think in anything in life
in general but I can only really speak
about like the influencer feel yeah I
can only speak about that feel because
that's the one I'm primarily active in I
think oftentimes like if you get caught
up in this I know it from personal
experience and I know it from just
witnessing it too often that if you stay
stuck in the complaining and the
negativity and what's wrong with the
system you're working within you won't
experience any level of growth and you
won't know how to work around these
things going through these really quick
the 95-percent process Thanks so many
times we have to just wait especially
with what we do for the biggest trailers
well happens a lot of the time is like
we covered like a huge tree that comes
out 6:00 to 9:00 a.m. in the morning
sometime there right and those are real
like though you got to get those up
right away especially if you're not one
of the top performing channels you are
going to really need to rely on being
recommended or suggested something like
that in order to really thrive the
stress that occurs when so your video is
stuck in 95% cuz on average it's like
one minute intro would do the trailer
reaction which is like two three minutes
and then we talked for about 10 minutes
reviewing the trailer you're waiting for
the process to finish it is so
stressful and sometimes it just doesn't
happen then you have to re-upload it a
little bit for Comic Con we did a
livestream and it went great it was I
love the live stream and then it took
about 48 hours for it to process that's
it and then finish going up on YouTube
and then because of the time I've
finished the process that effect the
algorithm of the preceding videos so
yeah I can relate with that spam
comments I don't know I don't even
notice them anymore honestly it was like
whatever love them ago they're just a
comment let it happen
yellow dollar bill signs always deal
with that to me the yellow dollar bill
sign doesn't make any sense anymore
especially because of the fact of how
it's handled I don't agree with the way
they do it I'm not exactly opposed
towards it though especially when we've
had to readjust for advertisers
considering the big 750 million dollar
pullout they had a couple years ago that
started all this I just think the system
needs to change a little because nine
point nine times out of ten we have a
weekly we do a video it gets the L
Addabbo sign literally it's so rare
where they're like not it's it's not
advertiser friendly so rare so rare so I
just think that instead of having this
clearly faulty automated system everyone
is going to request review anyway for
you guys you don't know you get a yellow
dollar bill sign you hit request review
someone purchase I don't know who one of
the thousands of employees they have
looking over this year child indicator
probably like how people talked about
here they let it go philip defranco is
constantly talking about this issue so
I'm just like well if everyone's gonna
hit review why don't you just review it
first before you give it a yellow dollar
bill sign and then just give it a yellow
dollar bill sign if it's clearly not
gonna be advertiser friendly you get 80
to 90% of your views within that first
24 hours where it's not reviewed and
then you make literally no money off of
it and it's really it's really sad I
think it's just one of those cases where
it's impossible because there's just too
much content I think they went with the
approach of let's just make this system
that they said was supposed to be smart
and was supposed to learn and I don't
know if it is I feel like they led with
let's just flag on the really cautionary
side then if people don't like it they
can a requester
you know like that's the sense I get is
sort of blanket them all protect the
advertise
it doesn't make sense to me when I feel
like more than 90% of the people who get
that yellow dollar bill sign will
request the review anyway if it's
already going to be reviewed you might
as well just review it first before you
do that it's not saving any one time and
at that point you are kind of just
pocketing a lot of money that could be
going towards the content creators who
have worked their asses off on this
video and the corporate thing I get why
people are upset about it because of the
fact that what YouTube or with its
original cause was and how it did stem
from just people and now corporations
have sort of taken over in terms of like
what's most popular on what's most
recommended and you know I remember
there's this whole thing that a corridor
a crew was talking about something h3h3
talked about with how you know you'll
see this talk show people talking about
gun violence and that's on the trending
page with h3h3 we'll get yellow dollar
bill signs instead this whole thing will
be done like YouTube doesn't tell your
little standard they don't really tell
you anything of what's going on behind
the scenes they don't like literally I
remember when suddenly the the view
count dropped significantly by millions
of views within a within a within a
month with this channel I had no idea
what was going on I had to have someone
else tell me like oh yeah you gotta
watch this video from like philip
defranco who found this happen YouTube
is an announced [ __ ] to you but with
corporate name going on I'm not too
bothered by it
I suppose it's like kind of a bummer in
a sense but I don't really have that
much nostalgia with the roots of YouTube
to be upset with it to me it's just kind
of expected with anything that becomes
this popular and this reliable for
cheaper forms of advertisement it just
makes sense to me more people are on
YouTube than they're watching TV now and
so I think they had they realized that a
lot of these at least entertainment
based corporation shows needed to kind
of to remind you through this platform
that their TV show does exist there are
things about it that I do think kind of
suck for the habitat as a whole in terms
of creation like yeah YouTube has
creators from average Joe just uploading
his first video today all the way up to
the most recognizable people in the
world and I think that's cool in and of
itself the notification belt issue
tell me about it doesn't seem
it doesn't it doesn't mean subscribe but
it's like someone brought up here that
they they stop hearing about subscribe
buttons a long time ago and yes like
you'll never hear us like really pushing
I only push for it when I'm like oh
we're so close to the next hundred
thousand mark normally I say subscriber
the real rejects after a videos dumb but
I wanted to say subscribe to the real
rejection because we are so close to
600k just a few hundred more were there
we're like a thousand away from 700,000
when we get to that point then cool it
feels nice I think subscriber counts
sure it can make a difference in terms
of like brand deals and and recognition
and it's cool I respect the people who
have like there's so many people who do
this kind of content who have way more
followers than us and mad respect them
at the same time though when it comes to
viewership it doesn't always make that
much of a difference you can find people
who have way more followers than us
every once in a while it's usually a
couple few videos within a month well
we'll cover the same exact video but
we'll get more views than that person
who has hundreds of thousands of more
followers than us subscriber accounts
just don't mean as much on what he
probably is a great point about it
didn't exist and they didn't grandfather
the men a lot of people who already
subscribed don't even think to hit that
notification bell it just makes sense
why now more than ever subscribe buttons
aren't as meaningful there is a time
where if you wanted to start up a
YouTube channel just go for it do it you
know have fun you know just be
consistent be patient and you'll get
there eventually now I always get a
little worried someone's like I'm
starting up a channel it might like
sometimes you know there are people who
still boom I'm Dave there's just a lot
of different stuff working against you
and there are a lot more corporate
channels to get through in terms of
hopping into the monetizable arena and
stuff it's not impossible but it's just
different it's a lot it's just a much
more challenging than ever before and
like what as he sued as he see the she
was bringing up about how people do
invest a lot of time and money when we
first started doing videos here it was
like just movie reviews weekly and it
was like hours and hours of editing and
assembly and then we had to
like well this isn't worth the time
right now so we nearly like really
trimmed down to one camera instead of
three oh yeah well I don't work around
this cell people work their asses off
and then in the beginning it can be
demotivating when you're like man I have
to get this many fun I have to do this
this much watch time this many
subscribers all these views they're like
so much to factor in just to get
monetized and it wasn't like that when
we started so feel like the early days
can be more discouraging now yeah gotta
have a thicker skin you got to have more
perseverance than ever but I used to
love YouTube I mean I'm still grateful
for it I would still can rather have the
complaints and struggles and issues that
this territory comes with more than any
other gig I can get right now more than
any other job I can get right now I
would much rather still I'll be able to
run my own home-based business do this
kind of content interact with followers
fans subscribers whatever you call it
have all these cool opportunities to
work with like studios and whatever go
on other channels of people like I've
been such a big fan of screen junkies
for so long and then the fact that I get
to go over to their place and film with
them now is like [ __ ] amazing to me
because I'm like I would gentleman like
a real fan of you guys you know so it's
it's pretty cool like the opportunities
it's allowed so I'm still grateful for
it and while there's tough times like
yeah you just got to be a lot more
mindful with spending and how I spend my
time and all these things and yadda
yadda yadda it's just constant
readjustment it's the way the in its way
any industry is there's always gonna be
you know like the shitty things you got
a deal with room for legitimate
complaints but then there's also got to
be that wiggle room of time move past it
now and what can we work with to still
thrive if you can be one of those guys
then you can still keep on going hey
know there was like is all the point
where people are like channels dead
channels dead but I'm like now you can't
say it anymore do we
average 50k views like we used to no we
don't we still have some videos that
within the past year during ad pocalypse
that have hit over a million views and
some of our biggest videos of all time
still come out within the last six
months so I'm like now we're still doing
fine and thanks to people at patreon as
well of helped keep us alive we're gonna
have to really worry about the view
count on YouTube as much as we used to
so thank you guys and to the brand's who
supports male channels that are
independent and stuff like this because
as much as people hate advertising
you do get to meet some pretty cool
people who are willing to work with you
and you know cool stuff can happen there
too mm-hmm so yeah I think there's I
think when times of trouble there's
still a lot of people who come around to
help out all right guys well thanks for
being here you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell Eric horseman happy birthday once
again to you buddy
much love we'll be talking some more on
the patreon and go ahead and check out
our patreon page two guys got a weekly
Q&A Stevie Show reaction stream along as
many of those shows have reaction
highlights included spend you know like
half the time editing for here and half
the time editing for there go check it
out